ce qui va nous intéresser aujourd'hui
c'est d'essayer de déterminer la
distance moyenne entre une planète du
système solaire et la terre
alors pour simplifier on va imaginer que
le soleil est au centre d'un système
dans lequel les planètes orbitent selon
des trajectoires parfaitement
circulaires
alors le cercle ici est pas très bien
dessiné mais vous pouvez imaginer qu'on
va faire la proximation que toutes les
planètes suivent des orbites
parfaitement circulaires alors dans la
réalité les orbites sont un peu
elliptiques un peu étirées mais ça reste
une très bonne approximation puisque
l'excentricité de ces ellipses est
relativement faible
donc on va imaginer deux planètes l'une
d'elles étant la terre
donc par exemple on va imaginer que
cette planète ici c'est la terre
et l'autre planète étant n'importe
laquelle des autres planètes du système
solaire donc par exemple on peut
imaginer et Vénus
ici au centre c'est le soleil
et ce qui nous intéresse c'est la
distance qui sépare la Terre et Vénus ou
l'autre planète tout au cours de l'année
en moyenne
alors pour calculer cette distance
moyenne on va s'appuyer sur un fait qui
est très important qui est le fait que
toutes les planètes suivent leur orbite
à des vitesses angulaires différentes
c'est à dire que lorsque la terre est
Vénus sont alignées par rapport au
Soleil à l'instant suivant la Terre aura
parcouru une distance différente en
termes d'angle et donc les deux planètes
ne seront plus alignées
en particulier ce que ça signifie c'est
que lorsque les planètes se décale et ne
sont plus alignées on va avoir un
triangle entre le soleil et les deux
planètes
ici on a un certain angle qu'on va
appeler theta et la distance qui nous
intéresse c'est cette distance là entre
les deux planètes donc la Terre et Vénus
et on voit ici que puisque les planètes
tournent sur leur orbite à une vitesse
constante et qu'elle tourne à deux
vitesses différentes et bien en réalité
cette Angleterre va varier au cours du
temps de façon linéaire et tracer tous
les angles possibles entre 0 et 2 pi
donc si nous intéresse en fait c'est la
moyenne de cette distance qu'on va
appeler D qui dépend de l'Angleterre par
rapport à téta lorsque têta varie entre
0 et 2 pi bon alors pour commencer on va
indiquer que la distance terre soleil
s'appelle grand air et que la distance
Vénus soleil s'appelle petit air ici on
voit qu'on a un triangle dont on connaît
l'un des angles et les deux côtés
adjacents et donc on va pouvoir utiliser
le théorème d'Al-Kashi la fameuse
formule des cosinus pour déterminer la
distance au carré
donc le théorème d'Al-Kashi nous indique
que cette distance ici
lorsqu'on la met au carré est égale à r
carré
+ petit r carré donc ça c'est le
théorème de Pythagore moins deux fois
les deux côtés fois le cosinus de
l'angle qui les sépare
donc ça c'est un théorème qu'on apprend
au lycée en fait ça se démontre assez
facilement si on travaille dans un
repère donc si on place par exemple la
terre et le soleil ici et qu'on a Vénus
qui est ici avec l'angle Teta et bien on
voit assez facilement qu'on a un
triangle rectangle ici
dont un côté est petit air sinus têta
l'autre côté est grand air moins petit
air cosinus Teta et lorsqu'on fait la
somme des carrés de ces deux grandeurs
on obtient bien la formule donnée
ci-dessus
bon et bien à partir de cette formule on
va pouvoir calculer la moyenne lorsque
thêta varie entre 0 et 2 pi et déterminé
donc la distance moyenne qui sépare les
deux planètes donc la première chose
qu'on souhaite faire c'est obtenir la
distance en passant le tout à la racine
carrée
et maintenant on va faire la moyenne de
cette distance alors comment calculer la
moyenne pour toutes les valeurs de cette
grandeur d lorsque têta varie entre 0 et
2 pi généralement pour calculer une
moyenne on a un certain nombre de points
fixés
et on somme la valeur de tous ces points
et on divise le tout par le nombre de
points le problème c'est qu'ici on n'a
pas un nombre de points discret on a une
fonction continue donc à l'inverse ici
on a un axe thêta
et une fonction D qui entre 0 et 2 pi
trace une certaine courbe
et donc ce qu'on veut faire en fait
c'est la somme de toutes les valeurs que
prend la fonction sur cette courbe donc
une somme d'une infinité continue de
valeur et divisée par le nombre de
valeurs qui se trouve ici c'est à dire
en fait diviser par la longueur de cette
intervalle
alors une somme infinie continue comme
ça c'est ce qu'on appelle en
mathématiques une intégrale donc ce
qu'on va faire c'est l'intégrale de D
qui est une fonction de theta par
rapport à téta entre 0 et 2 pi et on
veut diviser le tout par la longueur de
l'intervalle qui est de PI et ça c'est
la distance moyenne qui sépare les deux
planètes
bon et bien a priori il suffit seulement
de remplacer des deux tétas par cette
expression et de calculer l'intégrale
alors c'est parti on a un sur deux pi de
l'intégrale de 0 à 2 pi
de racine carrée
de r carré + petit r carré moins 2 R
cosinus Teta
des états
ici malheureusement on obtient une
expression qui est assez complexe et on
voit difficilement comment on pourrait
calculer cette intégrale
alors une première chose qu'on peut
faire pour simplifier un peu c'est
d'imaginer que la distance de la Terre
vaut simplement 1 alors ça ça n'est pas
complètement absurde si on choisit les
bonnes unités et en particulier si on
choisit des unités astronomiques
ua et bien on va mesurer les distances
en fonction du nombre de fois qu'elle
représente la distance Terre-Soleil donc
dans ce système d'unité les unités
astronomiques la distance Terre-Soleil
vaut simplement un ou plus précisément
une unité astronomique et la distance
Soleil Vénus est plus petite elle voit à
peu près 0,7 unité astronomique
donc ceci nous aide à simplifier on peut
remplacer grand air la distance
Terre-Soleil par 1
et on obtient la racine carrée de 1 + R
carré - 2R Costa
et si on voit que lorsqu'on aura intégré
téta ne sera plus une variable puisque
têta on intègre et donc la seule
variable qui reste c'est R et donc en
particulier la distance moyenne ne
dépend que de petit air
donc ici on a une fonction qui nous dit
la distance moyenne entre la Terre et
une planète en fonction de petit air
c'est-à-dire le rapport le ratio entre
la distance soleil planète et la
distance soleil terre
alors malheureusement cette intégrale
est impossible à calculer de façon
analytique on ne peut pas donner une
expression qui dépend de fonctions
usuelles comme des cosinus des racines
carrées ou des puissances et donc on est
obligé de la laisser sous cette forme
plus précisément c'est ce qu'on appelle
une intégrale
elliptique et c'est assez connu que ce
genre d'intégrale ne peut pas s'exprimer
sous la forme de fonction usuelle mais
heureusement on peut utiliser des
logiciels pour tracer le graphe de cette
fonction
et donc lorsqu'on trace cette fonction
avec en abscisse petit air et en ordonné
donc la distance moyenne on obtient une
courbe qui a cette forme là
ici on a une unité astronomique pour
zéro unité astronomique d'abscisse et
puis ensuite la courbe monte donc ce
qu'on peut voir ici c'est que pour une
planète qui orbiterait tout proche du
Soleil et bien la distance moyenne avec
la terre serait de une unité
astronomique et ça ça fait assez sens
une planète qui orbiterait tout proche
du Soleil ici et bien on voit que la
distance entre la Terre et cette planète
est toujours d'à peu près une unité
astronomique la distance terre soleil
mais une chose très étonnante que l'on
peut voir dans cette sur ce graphe c'est
que le graphe est parfaitement croissant
c'est-à-dire que quel que soit la
planète plus elle est loin du soleil
plus elle est également loin de la Terre
en moyenne donc de façon assez étonnante
Vénus ici qui semble sur ce diagramme
plus proche de la Terre et bien en
moyenne lorsqu'on prend toutes ses
positions le long de son orbite elle est
plus éloignée de la terre que le soleil
et donc mercure est plus proche de la
Terre en moyenne que Vénus et de la même
façon mars est plus éloignée de la terre
en moyenne que Mercure
enfin on voit que ce graphe tend vers
une fonction linéaire en fait on peut le
voir assez facilement ici lorsque petit
air est très grand le r carré ici
l'emporte sur les deux autres termes et
donc on obtient simplement la racine
carrée de r carré c'est-à-dire en fait
petit R et lorsqu'on intègre entre 0 et
de pi on obtient deux pi fois petit R
qui vient s'annuler avec le 1 sur 2 pi
et donc la distance moyenne pour une
planète qui est très éloignée et bien
c'est simplement la distance entre cette
planète et le Soleil